virtual conferences they put us in the
position to do what we have not done
before which is giving a pre-recorded
talk this video has seven tips for you
on how to improve your pre-recorded
videos enjoy for a researcher there are
three key points for success the ability
of speaking writing and the values of
the presented ideas but since you are
interested in this topic of recording
talks for a virtual conference I assume
the two points below are no problem for
you you just got a written paper
accepted for its valuable contents and
ideas so this video will be about the
first point specifically about your
ability to speak and record a talk for a
virtual presentation
I know research conferences are drawing
as researchers from various corners of
the earth and for many of us English is
not a native language this is one more
reason to speak slowly enough and most
importantly clearly less like this
because I'm going to talk about my work
and I will present everywhere and more
like this hello there my name is ITT
apocalypse ku and I'm going to talk to
you about multi-modality
the second point I'm going to talk about
is smiling you are presenting your work
that just got accepted at a conference
so please do not speak like you are
attending a funeral
smile a little in this will not only
enlighten your face but also your voice
will become more pleasant camera
specifications are not exactly the most
important issue here since nobody wants
to see all your pores on your face but
very important is the camera position
many of us record with the laptop camera
this delivers the perfect angle for the
viewer to inspect your nostrils keep in
mind to place the camera aligned to your
face to deliver an optimal result
not everybody has a podcast microphone
but consider buying one kidding kidding
but whatever microphone you plan to use
to not choose the oldest iPhone headset
lying around in your home but perhaps
consider buying a new one and spending
forty euros for a better microphone no
they don't pay me for this it will help
you with recording but also in the
numerous zoom meetings one needs to
attend these days if your microphone
does not always have a white noise or a
peeping sound attached to it people will
be involuntarily less disturbed when you
are speaking to them if your voice and
audio are pleasant people will be
pleasant to you
not all of us are perfect public
speakers and while recording a video
there is also no audience hearing you
right then the lack of audience will not
deliver you the adrenaline that would
flow on a stage while speaking live so
the concentration is of course reduced
while recording this is why instead of
doing n attempts until you do it all
right consider doing a minimum of
cutting the video software like KD and
life is very easy to use and available
for all operating systems possibly an
alternative to post editing is the
compilation of a script to which you
either stick closely or even read from
but it is very important to do two
things if you're working with a script
don't write it like you would write a
paper but write it like you would
explain to a colleague what you are
doing otherwise your audience will have
a hard time understanding you secondly
do not forget to interpret this script
say it like you mean it like you would
perform in theatre in the last tip I
have for you relax if you start some
time in advance before the video hand in
deadline you will have a lot of time for
trial for trial and error until you do
it right and if you are post editing do
not hesitate to record everything in one
imperfect cut and and then and then
repeat the bad parts like nothing
happened because you will remove
mistakes in post editing anyway I really
hope that this video helps you record
better videos I am really curious to
read about your experience in the
comments do not forget to hit like and
subscribe our trials and see you next
time okay bye
[Music]